san paolo la urbe más poblada de brasil
es hoy la capital de los sintecho unos
66.000 indigentes mal viven en las
calles de la ciudad más rica del país
según varias ongs este dato duplica las
cifras oficiales y revela un aumento de
casi tres veces desde el último censo
oficial realizado hace dos años antes de
la pandemia
esta iglesia es un remanso de paz donde
esas personas se encuentran comida y
afecto
desde las 7 de la mañana la actividad es
frenética todos los días el padre julio
lancelot y sirve el desayuno a más de
600 personas sin hogar
en moca un tradicional barrio de san
paolo este sacerdote es muy popular
en los últimos dos años la cantidad de
personas que frecuentan este comedor
social se ha disparado
es la crisis que estamos viviendo
agravada por la pandemia número sin
techo aumenta en sao paulo por encima
del crecimiento demográfico de la ciudad
eso es espantosa
en san paolo el 1 por ciento de los
dueños de inmuebles concentra en sus
manos el
45% del valor inmobiliario los
trabajadores de baja renta no pueden
pagar un alquiler
[Música]
algunos consiguen escapar de la
precariedad ocupando edificios públicos
abandonados
[Música]
o la duda hola chicos
buenos días
este mueble ocupado en noviembre de 2021
funcionaba como un asilo para ancianos
hoy abriga a 62 familias y es
administrado por mujeres
y aquí es donde mi madre duerme con mi
hermana en el otro colchón duerme mi
hermano la okupación intenta paliar el
problema estructural de la falta de
vivienda san paolo tiene un déficit de
323 mil pisos paradójicamente hay 290
mil edificios vacíos en este contexto
ocupar se convierte en un acto político
no estamos aquí porque nos parezca
bonito estamos aquí por necesidad un
alquiler hoy cuesta 240 dólares es casi
lo que yo gano no puedo pagarlo somos mi
marido mi hijo y yo
en otro barrio de san paolo la mano
invisible de la solidaridad se
concretiza a través del esfuerzo de
activistas voluntarios y organiza estas
cosas mientras yo cojo estas bolsas
varias veces por semana llevan agua y
mantas a los sin techo de la plaza
princesa isabel
estamos yendo a la nueva crack hollande
ya porque la vieja fue desalojada el 19
de marzo
la caracola nya surgió hace más de 30
años en el centro y llegó a concentrar a
25 mil personas por día
activistas como valeria denuncian que el
gobierno de san paulo no tiene voluntad
de solucionar este problema y se limita
a cambiar la cara hollandia del lugar
para revalorizar algunas calles del
centro
mañana volvemos para traer más mantas
con la llegada del otoño tropical el
frío aprieta y las donaciones son muy
esperadas
la policía está en todas partes como
pueden ver pero no consigue acabar con
eso son muy fuertes no consiguen
dispersarlos y arrestarlos hay intereses
políticos en todo esto
pocos días después la policía desmanteló
también este campamento un hombre murió
durante la operación
desde entonces los usuarios de crack
deambulan por el centro de san paolo en
busca de una nueva morada
río de janeiro es la postal de brasil
cada año cerca de un millón de turistas
visitan la ciudad maravillosa
copacabana el barrio más cosmopolita
también atrae a muchos mendigos que ven
en el alto poder adquisitivo de sus
habitantes una fuente de sustento
de vez en cuando un grupo de vecinos
sale al malecón para exigir más acción a
las autoridades
ellos nos agreden cuando vamos al banco
a sacar dinero no tenemos la culpa de
todo eso trabajamos fuimos educadas
pudimos optar por una vida mejor
eduardo es uno de los organizadores de
la manifestación
este pescador nació en copacabana usa
las redes sociales para sensibilizar a
los vecinos del barrio sobre el
incremento de los usuarios de crack que
llegaron a instalarse en esta colonia
tenemos muchas islas aquí en brasil que
podríamos hacer tomar a estas personas
llevarlas a las islas y hacer un
seguimiento ellos va a poder nadar desde
la isla hasta el continente es allí
donde entra la recuperación
eduardo sostiene que la mayoría de los
sintecho en copacabana son
drogodependientes
yo como carioca me siento muy triste
cuando presencié una situación como esta
tan embarazosa
en brasil el 82 por ciento de los
sintechos son varones dos de cada tres
son negros y tienen menos de 44 años el
desempleo las drogas y los problemas
familiares los llevaron a la calle